is you don't portray yourself like a
virgin which is which is a which is a
great you know based on that you're born
I'm saying it's like
[Applause]
and I think you're counting I'll be
stupid yeah I think you're capping no
okay thank you I'm copying for my
Instagram but nobody has version
no yeah but usually like I've had virgin
girls come on the show where nobody
really nobody really like wait wait
nobody really like pushes back right but
it's not like it's just it's a good
thing right that's like a great thing I
think that's awesome it is good but it's
like it's like unfortunate because I'm
like No One Believes you because of the
Instagram
it's like it's like it loses but yeah
that's a great thing nobody has that
that's why I want to change my Instagram
too
I'm gonna go home and archive okay